Well,
well,
well go to your mom's house
Christina,
cause it's interesting.
Oh my brother,
oh my gosh.
Bird book racers for so bad.
I enjoy
working today
beyond the least.
God,
here you go.
Verdis fat.
Our guest today,
burnt crystals coming on in just a moment.
The fattest drunkest comedian working of all time.
Uh,
that's gaping dad.
But that great song.
Um,
so definitely wanted to give him a shadow.
Many Burdis fat songs.
Gene,
really big news.
Uh,
not only are you on the road this week,
what you're going to tell everybody about,
but Sunday we're doing the podcast live at the sperm vine Improv,
the podcast.
The podcast is going to be alive in sperm vine at the sperm vine Improv.
That's Irvine,
California.
If you are around Orange County near it,
La,
head down Sunday Improv and we'll do the podcast.
All right,
let's,
uh,
make sure you check out,
Christina and she was going to be at the,
um,
let's see.
She is going to be Zany is in Nashville.
That's going to be this Tuesday.
And then Wednesday she's going to be at the comedy zone in Charlotte,
North Carolina.
So make sure you check her out there.
Christina p online of course,
huge news.
The podcast airs,
excuse me,
the uh,
special of her as mother inferior coming out
next Tuesday,
the 10th.
And we're super excited about it.
So make sure you put it in your queue and get ready to watch Christina p mother
and fear.
You're only on Netflix.
We have a very exciting,
uh,
guests here in studio today.
It is
a,
I found,
is that the,
that's you saying it?
Yeah,
that's it.
You saying it,
you said it in a phone call while you were doing a press somewhere
and they were like,
what's going on?
And then you,
you said,
oh yeah,
I remember that.
The,
this is that right when I was doing a huge press tour to like 140 radio station?
Yes.
I think so.
All of your fans changed my Wikipedia page.
Yeah.
We're price your legs digging holes and maybe harms and you know what to open
this show.
You know,
this guy took of that
interview and he made,
his name was gaping dad and he made an amazing song out of it.
I don't know if you've ever heard it,
but here's just,
I won't play the whole thing again,
but here's a,
a portion of it.
This guy took that interview.
I'm just serious like a,
at the skill level of some of the,
I have none of those fans by the way.
No one ever.
No one ever makes me songs.
No one ever makes me pictures.
Like everyone talks about,
oh my fans made these great artwork and I'm like,
I thought we all have the same fucking fans.
Oh my God,
I'm
already like this.
I can do this and fucking garage band,
check it out.
That's not that bad.
I couldn't do this.
I take that back.
That is one of the things that like,
it is,
it is the true thing of insanity.
It's like,
uh,
cause we were,
we were talking about slut shaming because Georgia was talking to sandy about
sound about her friends.
Uh,
I said something,
she fell and I was like,
oh baby.
She was crying.
I go,
baby,
why are you crying?
She's like,
everyone likes him better than me.
And I was like,
no,
you're beautiful,
you're cool.
She's like,
Dad,
I'm not cool.
I'm going to know you are a cool.
She goes down,
I'm actually not cool at school.
All the cool girls have been at least three boyfriends.
I go,
oh no,
those are slots baby.
Their slots.
And I go,
that's how they're being cool.
Now it's a,
it's a shortcut but we'll come to high school.
When they want a data girl,
they're going to go to you cause no one's going to want to date a girl who's had
five boyfriends.
No one's going to want to marry the girl that's had five but a hundred
boyfriends snowman.
I go,
look,
I'm telling you about slut shaming for real.
Cause I did it.
I was a part of the,
the bad part of slut shaming.
Like is it?
But I only because I go there are boys that are equal to you in life that
aren't,
that don't have a girlfriend.
And when they get to high school,
they see it,
that same rejection you feel they will feel and apply it by calling them sluts.
That's how it's done.
I go,
I'm not for it.
And then my wife got ill,
he got really upset.
She's like,
that's top of the fucking slut shaming thing.
But here's the crazy thing about slut shaming is said it's not real.
It's not,
these girls haven't done anything.
It will happen.
They've,
all they've done is like dated boys,
but then it'll get around.
It'll be rumors.
That's the thing with the fucking Burdis fat.
Yeah.
And even like it's,
is that you start,
by the way,
I was fat as fuck when that happened,
but like,
wait,
how surprised were you?
And that's true.
Wait,
because I was fat.
I was to 65 when that started.
I was two 65.
How do you think you got there?
For Real?
Oh,
I'm thinking about it.
Yeah,
I do.
Uh,
number one,
uh,
I fell off a waterfall.
That was the number one.
That was the number.
Cause what we're like,
let's say go back a couple of years.
What was your walk around weight?
I was at 40 years old.
I was two 15,
two 16 and that was,
I was,
and I looked really good four years ago.
That's four years ago.
Yeah.
Travel Channel.
It's slowly built,
added on and added on.
I think I was floating around at two 35 probably what I was doing,
triple flip to 35 maybe,
maybe to 40.
Yeah,
I hurt.
I hurt my,
I blew out my,
uh,
Plantar Fasciitis,
playing tag football and I was getting back in shape and I,
and I couldn't walk.
I couldn't run.
And that's what it started putting it on.
And then when I fell off the waterfall,
and that's what I'm alone,
because I was,
I was addicted to oxy and value.
Oh my God.
Oh,
I was eating,
I was,
I was eating four.
I was taking oxy is four times a day.
Uh,
and I was taking four volumes of doubt.
I was taking them together and put the fucking Cabasa on that.
Good.
Yeah.
But that,
but that's what I,
cause I wasn't even getting out of bed.
I was like,
I couldn't move.
I remember being in a bed in a hotel room in North Carolina and I couldn't get
out because I couldn't reach my oxies or my,
well,
I can say oxies whatever they were vicodins whatever they were.
I don't know if it was an what knocks the cotton,
but it was oxycodone or whatever.
It's going to rain or whatever,
whatever it was was pretty awesome.
They were really great and I couldn't get out of bed and I pissed in the bed
because I couldn't get my get my pills because I couldn't,
I couldn't move my back.
Yeah.
But that,
I think that added on.
And then that last season of birth conquer,
I just power eight.
This is what came,
this is why we brought it down.
I need to ask him.
That's Gerard Depardieu and he was doing this.
Oh my God.
That's why we were watching this movie.
We were watching this movie and as a joke we were talking about the movie.
Yeah.
And the right before that whole thing took off,
I was like,
oh he looks like he has Burt stomach and that and that day when we did that,
when we talked about that,
that's when we started to like talk about it basically that that day
that was what,
but I didn't want a notice.
Like I really didn't catch on to it.
Like I'd see them,
but I'll be like,
hey,
I'm not fat.
But I really was that and I was doing that weight loss challenge at the time.
I was challenging myself to on most doodle blog and you guys watch it and you're
like,
what the fuck you doing a Vlog for?
What are you 13
wait,
this is once it started though.
Once we started challenging you can go,
I think it was right before that.
I think you saw that too number when he started doing blogs.
It was when I was pregnant with Ellis and we all had dinner and he's like,
look at this blue.
Oh that's your guys.
You guys were like,
I remember you'd be like fucking seriously.
Yeah,
cause it was at dinner.
What were you eating on birth to conquer or like what was your jam?
Okay,
so no number one.
Uh,
we used to do a thing called crew,
crew skis.
So we'd had a big crews.
And then what that would be was that I got to order for everybody and then I,
and in doing that,
what I would do is I would order everything I wanted to eat and then we'd cut it
up.
And you could sample thing.
Yeah,
I've been with you.
We did that in Montreal.
It's the fucking best,
but you always order a lot when you,
you always order a couple plates extra.
So I was ordering and then it started turning out.
When I go out to eat with people,
I'd order two meals cause I didn't want,
because I still use the cruise skis,
but having options that I didn't want one to suck and you know,
and they go,
oh that was my meal.
So I had ordered two meals and then I'd,
I'd make it rain appetizers and a,
I think that,
and I switched over.
I was drinking a lot of beer at the time.
And so I think he's just started adding up.
I was just,
no,
I know I'm,
I'm thinking about it in my own thing.
Like I always been pretty big boy,
but it really got off the rails when she got pregnant.
It really was,
we would go out to a who go out to practice every day and we'd always be like,
got to have dessert for breakfast.
So I would,
who are you?
You're the one that I that I don't think people have it in their memory of how
big you were.
How big were you at your biggest
well,
what triggered,
like when I remember,
you know you have like a weight you're comfortable with.
So I remember being like thinking that like two 45 for whatever reason was fine.
And then at two 55 I remember just being like,
yeah,
but that's like two 45
or business.
I like to shave the hard corners off the truth.
Yeah.
So like if somebody said like,
how much do you weigh?
When I went to 55 I'd be say two 45 and in my mind I'd be like,
that's not really a lie cause I'm like within range.
And then I can actually remember getting on scales and seeing like two 58 and
two 61 and like I remember when it was,
when once it's across to 60 I was like,
you're definitely not close to 45 no more scales.
But the worst with that.
So that the one where I was like,
I really,
cause I had,
you know,
I had fucked with,
I mean I had trainers,
I had,
I had a trainer during her pregnancy and we used to go to boot camp together.
But I'm saying yes,
we used to go to bootcamp,
which absolutely was death,
but this trainer,
I mean he was really having me fucking do tire flips and like,
you know,
then wind sprints then run over and do power cleans and like I would do these
workouts that were like absolutely killing me,
but then I would eat absolutely everything afterwards.
Do you remember the time that we went and we did crossfit?
I was like,
I think I burned like 10,000 calories
through the time we did cross fit and then we went out with Chris.
I Walker her.
Yes.
Yeah.
With,
with the gay bars and we had so much fun and we're killing gay drinks,
like all those sugary things.
And then at the end of the night we're like,
I've were,
we did good today.
We went to crossfit,
crossfit and all we had were some vodka drinks and then Chris is like,
who wants pizza?
We're like,
you're a trainer.
You're supposed to be keeping us away from this.
And we murdered
and we thought like if he's pizza,
yeah,
he's greenlighting.
Yeah.
He's saying go ahead and do it.
But that's the problem with exercise is that you don't gauge how much you should
be eating because you won't get burned all these calories.
Yeah.
Do whatever you want to figure out that if you do that kind of exercise and then
eat right,
then that,
yeah.
Then it,
whoa.
My thing,
the I,
when I,
when we were doing that weight loss challenge,
I would just,
uh,
I would,
I would eat very like lean and clean,
like kind of like I am right now because of this challenge.
I love parameters.
I love being challenged.
I love,
yeah,
I love to focus on stuff.
And uh,
and then I take an Ambien at night and be like,
I'm not eating dinner.
I take an Ambien and I go to sleep and I wake up skinny.
Yeah.
And that's the key.
If you can skip dinner.
Oh,
that's what I do.
Yeah.
That's how I lost weight.
I weighed two oh eight when I delivered ls,
so I had a lot of baby weight to lose and that was the single trick.
I did no alcohol at night.
And don't eat dinner.
Why do you have to eat dinner?
Have a bowl of vegetable soup and just go to fucking bed.
All of vegetable soup.
Janet's mood I like to do,
I'd like to make the girls,
uh,
vegetable.
Uh,
I make um,
uh,
matzah ball soup with chicken,
noodles and everything.
And then I put two whole chickens in there and then I just pull out the chicken
and eat the chicken with the broth or you go,
that's good.
That's great.
Yeah.
But the sweat pants also are a big,
uh,
a big codependent friend when you're gaining weight because if you wear it,
I started wearing sweat pants and hoodies everywhere.
That's the Billy Gardell died.
I love you Billy.
But Billy who does wear sweat pants everywhere.
And I was like really?
Like,
but man,
they are like an enabler.
That's so true.
Like you're looking good,
Bert.
You could sit criss cross apple sauce and then you go to put on your genes and
your genes are like,
oh,
we need to talk.
Yeah.
Jeans are always the,
uh,
the indicator of where you're at with your weight.
For me,
I can always tell where I am emotionally by which genes I can fit into.
Yeah.
So now look at your face today at your face.
Looks extra clear.
Doesn't he look really like clear?
Yeah.
Like his eyes and,
and you don't look puffy at all.
You look great.
They're really fat picture.
Yeah.
Of you are meeting with me.
So this is uh,
right before weight loss challenge starts.
This is like,
so this is the no wait,
no.
Oh my God.
Tom,
I know you're Super Husky.
What was that shirt?
What size?
Shit.
What's that shirt like?
Triple x?
No.
Yeah.
You know I started,
my dad would buy me double axes.
Yeah.
And at the time when I started the weight loss I wanted to do,
I went to go run and I put on one of the double x is not knowing,
it was a double act and it was still a little tight on my belly.
And I went,
Oh shit,
I'm a legit double X.
Is that,
oh it's scary.
You know the most other painful thing is when like I saw people then and I see
them now.
It's like it's a super narcissistic and they don't say anything and I'm like,
it just shows you like how people are only wrapped up in themselves.
But I'm like,
yeah,
I'll be like,
we saw each other last time,
odd ball.
And they'll be like,
yeah.
And I'm like,
I don't look different to you.
And they're like,
I don't know.
Do you like Jesus Christ?
Man,
I lost like a fucking fifth grader.
And like,
they're like,
I didn't really notice.
I get,
well,
I think I lose weight so quickly that everyone says it,
that that one week they see me because I lost so much weight in,
uh,
in like the first two weeks of December that everyone that saw me during pickup
or drop off was like,
Holy Shit,
what happened?
But I lost probably 20 pounds that first two weeks.
Yeah,
I lost it.
I lost a ridiculous amount of weight that just cutting out booze.
It's first.
I bet you're just bloated first.
It's a lot of bloat.
And then it's also,
um,
it's just,
it's just saying to myself,
hey,
I can't eat everything I want.
Like,
I like,
I,
that's,
that's what that guy was,
judge you.
I never thought of anything like,
and I was still,
you know what,
as,
as others,
fat person thought that like,
you don't realize until afterwards you think when you're fat that,
that other people don't enjoy food as much.
So like when someone,
when you're like,
yeah,
you're like,
well,
the reason that I'm eating these chocolate croissants is because I really
appreciate the way they taste.
Like this guy who,
who's not so it doesn't know good food.
And they were like,
no,
I know it.
I'm not a pig so I'm not eating them all the time.
And then you're like,
oh yeah,
I thought that I thought that I was just somebody that enjoyed food and that's
why I was eating and we just enjoyed a lot of it thing.
And I noticed when I was getting fat,
I was pregnant.
Right.
But then after two,
like you still,
like I was still eating the same way I was when I was pregnant.
And then you feel out of control.
I didn't like that feeling.
It was too much.
And it doesn't feel good.
It feels better to have half the croissant.
Right.
Tommy?
Definitely once every now and then or whatever,
you know,
I go,
I go through such long periods now of going without sugar that I'll,
I'll think of it as I'll think of the sugar as a reward.
So I'll be like,
I haven't had like a,
a real sweet treat in a,
and then
what happens is that like the,
so there's this bill build up and anticipation for it and then when I have like
even part of it I'm like sometimes I'm like as good but I don't want the whole
thing anymore.
Like I'll just pay on it now.
Cause part of it is that like the,
it's not as good as you imagine it's going to be.
And a part of it makes me feel like I'm not that way with alcohol.
When I built it up and I have it,
I go,
it's just as good as I remembered it
because like I feel like I,
but like a real alcohol buzz is really going to make somebody feel good morning
beer.
Buzz is like one of my favorite things in the world.
Don't understand.
I don't understand that.
I'm talking about,
have you ever drank beer early,
early morning?
I mean I taught a cruise.
Oh my problem is,
I don't know if it's,
I think it's a lyric and Miss Sheryl crow song,
that's how great it is.
I feel like,
I feel like booze,
daytime booze,
90% of the time for me means a nap is 15 minutes away.
Feel like going to sleep.
I just don't have,
I,
I it has to be evening for me to enjoy.
I have different perspective over these last two days because my,
and I only say this because I think we,
I don't know if we talked about this or not,
but like,
so when we started the October,
October,
sober October a challenge and uh,
been here over 10 minutes and haven't had any alcohol yet
by the way.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't be the first time I your podcast,
I walked in with a 12 pack.
I think I come off a plane.
Remember the last time we flew together?
Remember how big it was?
Probably bigger than that
Styrofoam Cup.
No,
a 30 to clarify those 30 12 to a vodka sodas I were making.
We were a little out of control.
Yeah.
By the way.
And I don't,
I haven't really figured it out.
And,
um,
I jumped in therapy tomorrow and I'm going to talk to my therapist about doing
some,
I might just like while the girls are in school out of Burbank to a quick flight
somewhere,
a quick flight back to just work on it.
But like the,
my biggest problem with booze is flights.
It's no questions asked the for you also just did it.
Okay.
Bye.
I didn't think,
I don't know if I did it out of spite.
I don't know why.
I don't know.
But how hard was,
it wasn't,
so it was almost embarrassingly easy in that I want you to the airport.
And I went what was like,
oh wow.
I actually feel pretty good.
I was real talkative.
I'm not,
not that I'm not talking about,
but when you are drinking in the morning you don't really talk to people.
You just,
only because you don't want to look drunk.
Cause that's a real red flag of like why has he been drinking?
And you're like,
well,
I'm scared of fucking flying,
but when you're not drunk,
I was very talkative and I was friendly and I,
and I got on the plane and I was like,
I was like,
okay,
I'm not freaking out yet.
But,
but because you guys had said the challenge,
you need to enter October,
I didn't drink that evening.
Although everyone at DC I'm sure thinks I was.
I was drinking soda water.
They're like,
I,
I killed my soda water.
And they went nuts and I was like,
Nah,
they don't want to tell him,
let him think it.
But I think because I entered the morning sober,
I think I didn't have sour stomach,
I didn't have like a sweaty at like a swamp ass.
Like all the things,
my brain,
when I am hung over,
I think it's when I'm hungover it will repeat things over and over again.
Like the same lyric.
Shiloh,
when I was young,
it will just do that over and over again and it makes me crazy.
And so I man,
when I was in Australia,
I'm telling you,
you don't know how to control it unless you saw me in Australia.
My tour manager was,
must have been like,
holy fuck,
I've been in a band for years.
I've never seen one like this.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean the photos looked pretty crazy.
It was a great trip.
Sold out shows fucking amazing.
So happy I did it.
But because Sydney was 1500 and we were like half sold at the beginning of the
tour,
I had to,
I had to literally fly,
perform,
fly,
perform.
Yeah.
And I,
I'm not good at that.
And that's not how the tour was set up.
The tour was set up,
fly,
uh,
rest of the day off show the next day.
And that's totally doable.
But man,
I was,
and they don't serve booze and the Quantas sounds until noon and all my flights
were at eight in the morning.
Um,
you have no idea.
Like how bad I was.
And then I go on this flight.
I know,
Dude.
I know.
It sounds like fucking craziness.
It's the morning alcohol that really,
and it's by the way,
in defense of other people,
cause I know you,
I know,
you know,
I know how well you can manage your life and I know what's going on with you.
But in defense of other people when they hear those stories is when people are
like,
oh,
this guy's a fucking drink,
a maniac.
Well,
drinking minute,
like,
uh,
I think Raj Rogan has been calling me a raging alcoholic,
which that's,
that's not accurate.
Only not because you never rage.
Yeah,
no,
but no,
but I mean like,
I'm not,
uh,
I don't change.
I'm not,
I don't change who I am.
And a lot of people I don't think can even tell him drunk when I'm drunk.
True.
And I'm not a mean person.
I think I'm a sweet person,
so,
and I don't,
and it doesn't affect my life negatively and aligning,
a lot of people would argue,
well,
you just haven't found your bottom,
but I'm sure your bottom will show up in the form of liver cancer or something
like that.
That's totally true.
But,
um,
but for the most part I think,
you know,
all I can say is that when I got on that plane,
I was embarrassed that I had allowed what,
whatever.
I'd allowed myself to get that far away from just trying to get over flying.
And I was on the plane and I'm like waiting for it to rear its head.
I'm waiting for it to go to like craziness to happen.
It never showed up.
And I went and an Ari and I talked about it this morning,
oddly enough,
uh,
after I had breakfast with Joey,
who,
Joey and I talked about it.
But,
um,
or is he doing sober October,
Joe?
Yes.
Yeah.
Is No,
no.
Uh,
yeah,
no hash
but,
or he's like,
you know,
when I was on,
I'm,
I'm sure he's cool with me sharing anything with it,
but it's like when I was on depression pills,
they were like,
sometimes you fix the problem,
but you still had the cast on.
So I might've,
I might've,
I'm not saying I have,
but I might've fixed my fear of flying with all this drinking,
but I've been doing it out of habit.
So I think that for the most part is
right or the fear of flying is the justification to start the day drinking
bad habit where you go,
you go,
I'm,
I'm allowed to do this.
This is how I
do.
You have to do this.
Cause I have this fear that needs to be managed.
But also like,
um,
it's a entry.
Flying became a nice excuse to take the day off and drink.
Dude,
can I tell you that the one realization I had,
by the way,
I'm by no stretch of the means,
am I this like sober guy.
And by the way,
hey,
if,
if you're my friend and you're in recovery,
don't hit me up.
I'm not in recovery.
Okay?
Like I don't,
I don't plan.
I'm not going to a fucking meeting and I don't want to go to lunch with you.
Like I don't want to sit and talk about sober
stop.
I'm a regular fucking person
though.
Not Regular people.
No,
no.
I don't want to talk like sober talk.
Yeah.
I don't want to get into that shit.
I just want to live my life.
Why?
What's wrong with the sober tower?
It's uh,
it's a little,
a little self involved.
It's a little like,
I just want to hang out with my kids and my family and workout and I,
and work.
The stuff that makes you drink.
No,
there's nothing that makes me drink.
I don't,
I easily can not drink.
I have no problem with that.
I can easily not smoke weed.
The,
I think my problem is,
uh,
once again,
and I,
this is the one realization,
I have it in snow,
like Apifany,
but like,
I think it's,
it's,
it's an excuse.
It's a habit that you get stuck into.
Like yet yesterday,
all I can say is that I,
I landed and I was,
I've never done this.
I got a coffee at the airport and I was like,
I was like,
I would never do that because I was like,
I don't want my stomach to turn on me.
Like,
I don't want,
if I'm going have to shit halfway through at home.
And so I got a coffee at the airport and was like,
and then called the Anna said,
uh,
what are we doing today?
I've never fucking said that.
And I've never been like,
what are we doing?
Everyone knows.
Do you know how that sounds?
I do.
I know.
What's the norm for you?
You get off the plane,
off
the plane,
come home,
take a nap,
have a cigar after scar taking nap guys.
Gotta re entry.
Uh,
and then we go over to friend's house,
have a big dinner and get over their own to everyone starts,
everyone has more cocktails and then that's our Sunday.
It's not,
I mean it's not,
but,
but I called her and I was like,
I was felt wide awake.
She was like,
she was like,
oh,
well we're going to Iowa softball game.
And I was like,
I said,
we ought to just started with softball up.
So I was like,
fuck yeah,
let's go to a softball game.
And then we went down to a softball game,
went to Rei.
We did all this cool shit.
And then I got home that night and I was like,
I kinda want to go for a jog.
And I was like,
Oh fuck,
what world is this?
Went for like a quick two mile jog just around the neighborhoods.
It was dark,
came back and was like,
uh,
I feel great.
I was like,
I'm going to bed unassisted sleep.
By the way,
I know that that's another thing that's going to fucking rock everyone's mind.
I don't often go to sleep without drugs or alcohol.
Right?
So it's not a big thing of mine.
Right.
I have a problem.
Leanne can just close your eyes like a fucking Mormon and be like,
I'm doing thinking for the day,
click like I literally embed and go crazy.
And Man,
I did let assisted sleep last night and I was like,
in my head I was like,
this is pretty cool.
I was,
and then I was like,
what am I gonna do tomorrow?
I was texting you guys.
Well,
we went over to any in Cody's house.
I was texting you guys like,
are we doing yoga in the morning?
What do they think?
Nothing.
Your sisters know.
Leah said the same thing.
Nothing.
What do you mean?
Like it's not the,
there's no difference in my personality.
There's no difference in anything.
It's just what did they think of you embarking on,
you know,
the challenge so to speak?
Uh,
they,
they don't know like it sounds,
my therapist was very much against it.
Why is that?
Why they're like,
I've been very transparent with my therapist and uh,
he was like,
I wouldn't advise you doing this before your trip to Australia and I wouldn't
advise 90 days and I wouldn't advise doing it for a bet.
And I was like,
really?
He goes,
yeah,
I mean,
he goes,
it just sounds like he goes,
it just sounds like a bad idea to me.
And Lance,
like,
do it.
She's like,
look,
I know you and these are the things that inspire you to change.
We've dropped all that weight,
La last year.
I've kept it all off that,
that,
that was changed,
legit change for me.
I think something like this for me,
it gives me an excuse.
You have no idea.
And I,
and I say this in like,
I'm not,
you have no idea how often people buy me drinks.
Like it is,
it is,
I think it would over fucking welcome you to see how often drinks are given to
me.
Like to the point when that,
that light,
I show Saturday when I didn't want to drink,
Taylor Tomlinson was like,
this is like when you're not drinking.
I don't realize how often.
Like it's just all over the place.
And so,
uh,
I was like,
it's a nice excuse to say no.
Yeah.
Like it just to be like no.
Doesn't that highlight to you like you saying that right now,
it doesn't,
that highlight to you how the people around you,
like your wife,
your sisters would be like,
whoa,
crazy.
You're going to take a month off?
No,
not my sister on the road,
on the road.
Not like families.
Never like,
you know,
but my family is all,
we drink when we get to.
Yeah,
of course.
But yeah,
my sister Leanne has to know how you were so excited.
She was like wanting to go on a walk with me and talk about what I'm feeling.
I love it.
And she was like,
let's go for a walk,
go for a walk.
And I was like,
I was like,
I'm super like pensive.
The thing,
the thing that's really bothered me is,
and by the way,
I'm not like I did Dr Drew's podcast and he was like,
everyone's saying that I needed medical assistance to stop drinking.
I was like,
I was like a little blown away.
Well,
but,
but that's also like all the fans
logical.
If a fan like a fan,
let's say a super fan of yours lives in,
I don't give a shit wherever Columbus and,
and you went and he saw you at the show,
shirtless pound and drinks.
He hung out with
you.
He saw 20 people by Utah.
Just shots and shots.
Right.
And then,
and then he also sees you on social media,
partying and sees your eyes,
I guess.
That's right.
I guess that's right.
Then they go,
you go like I'm quitting.
Like the normal healthy reaction reactions probably like,
is that all right for you to do?
I mean,
yeah,
but the one thing that's like I told you,
I ran into a guy,
I ran into someone who's like,
I had a row or a rough week this week.
I found me should I go see a doctor if I don't want to drink tonight?
And I think that misinformation,
uh,
Ha highlights people.
Maybe they shouldn't drink that guy dying from true blood was the one guy.
Everyone's like,
well,
if you drink a lot,
you can't just stop drinking.
So that was one of the things that I get fans be like,
well,
people think that some of them think that like you wake up and I start drinking,
you roll over.
Right.
And there's like a bottle of gin.
Yeah.
On Your nightstand and then you're like,
oh,
now I can sit up.
Yeah.
It's like,
uh,
what's the Vegas thing?
Oh,
right.
Nicolas Cage.
It's not that for you.
Yes,
I'm running.
I'm,
no,
I got it.
Now here's another thing,
but like,
I'm running on a treadmill now.
I'm running on the open road,
but the other day I ran five miles posted on my social media.
Today I ran three and a half last night.
I ran to like,
I'm running every fucking day.
I am working out.
I was going to crossfit like I'm,
I'm living an active life.
Right.
But I'm also partying at night when I'm home most often Tuesday,
Monday,
Tuesday,
I'm not drinking.
And you're able to do this because of your Mickey Mantle genes.
Right.
That's my Mickey managing.
Yeah.
Now Bert,
can I ask you something that,
yeah,
I mean that to me sounds really exhausting.
I'm 40 right?
You have,
I did not know how exhausting it was until I woke up this morning and went,
oh,
I have to fucking fantastic.
Right,
because you're not,
you're not fighting the hangover.
You're not running to offset the effects of alcohol.
Biggest thing before about when I look at Berg,
right.
And like when I see what he's doing,
what I feel the most is tired.
Yeah.
When I looked at him,
when I feel I'm exhausted,
man,
I feel like,
I feel like looking at what you're doing makes a lot.
Yeah.
Well I,
I think,
uh,
the one thing that I went to San Francisco,
I took two naps in one day with you.
I was,
I got to go lay down.
I'm very punitive.
So like I refuse to lay in bed and go feel so good today.
Yeah.
I go,
if you don't feel good,
get on the treadmill and let's run a fast mile on the treadmill.
Now I know that that's not,
that's fake,
right?
Yeah.
But it is exercise.
It is something,
of course it's on heart rate's going up yet I will say that Joe was accurate in
that running on the street is drastically fucking different.
So different.
Pushing your body forward is very different than moving your legs up and down.
But,
so,
um,
but I'm very punitive.
So like I would,
I would just get up and go,
I've got to work out.
I got to,
I got to work out.
I got to do something.
I can't just not,
I can't just lay,
but why can't see that's a thoughts.
I think that's the part where I'm hearing,
I'm like,
ah,
like my,
I just feel exhausted for you.
Cause it's that self punishing element.
Like,
yeah,
that's the crazy to me,
the I'm going at first it's the booze,
booze,
and then I'm going to wake up and then I'm going to punish myself.
What I did then I
think I have a little bit of OCD.
Yeah.
I think I have a little bit OCD,
uh,
and coupled with anxiety.
Why?
Why are they need to punish herself?
Why can't you just relax?
Why can't you just sleep in if you're not,
I don't know.
We've talked about this.
You've taught,
Tom and I have talked about this a lot.
I don't know.
I don't know what's wrong with me that I did.
I overbook myself every fucking week that I'd never take a week off that I,
I think
Aye.
I have no fucking idea.
I can ideas.
I don't know.
I think cause I feel like I'm not worth anything
if you're like,
no,
I think part of you,
you know there's a fear aspect to it,
which is not unnatural.
Like fear of like,
you know,
if I have things going away,
going away,
like you have a fear of letting people down.
You have a fear of that,
of someone not liking you.
Like
okay,
yeah you really do know these.
Keep going.
Yeah.
What else?
So I think there's,
there's that.
I think the other thing is that like,
you know,
we all laughed about your certainty that you could run the marathon,
and then you were like,
after your start running out doors,
you're like,
hey,
this is fucking way harder.
It's way harder.
But the reason I think the reason that you say I could definitely run it before
you realize how difficult it would be because,
because you think that's what a strong person would say.
Yeah.
A strong person is confident.
If the person says,
I can't run the marathon,
that person is weaker.
But in that scenario,
I think the person that says I would need a lot of time to prepare for that
marathon.
That's what I was,
that's what I was just realistic.
Not Realistic because you,
because of your high probe hyperbole tendencies.
Cause like I definitely,
I definitely,
today I was running and I was running,
I was running real slow and I was like,
I was like,
what's going on?
Like,
and I was like,
oh I did have a cigar this weekend.
Like is that it?
Within like I was like,
fuck man,
I'm running into,
I was running it at 10 minute and 22nd pace and it was hurting.
And I was like,
I was like,
shit man,
this isn't,
this is five hour marathon pace about,
it's about 11 minutes about that.
And I was like,
fuck,
I don't know if I could do this for 26 more miles.
And I was like,
I really couldn't.
But then part of me said
I bet I could punish myself into it.
Yeah.
Like I bet I could hurt myself into it.
I bet I could.
That's the other part that like I think that I put in the equation as I go.
Aye.
I like when we did that weight loss challenge,
I didn't have a problem eating less than a thousand calories a day.
I did my,
I'm punishing myself into losing the weight and I'm sure,
I'm sure someone's like,
man,
this,
uh,
this drinking thing,
you're just pulling your shirt.
Here's punishing yourself by not drinking.
I'm doubled up my therapy and I'm trying to figure it out.
I'm writing,
I'm writing every morning.
I'm writing as I,
as much as I can about my thoughts and my feelings because what I would like to
do ideally would,
uh,
would be get done this month and then go to New Orleans and have a good time and
not get fucking crazy like crazy and just have a good time and reset my clocks
so that I can enjoy alcohol and enjoy marijuana.
But it's not I,
but I,
I really think if I could,
if I can get my fucking,
well we are we just hearing,
wait,
you're telling me that you're,
you're doing your sobriety so you can plan the getting fucked up trip after the
trip is happening.
I had definitely had a lot of phone calls with everyone that works with me
saying,
you will be drinking on this trip.
People have bought tickets to drink with you on this trip.
But you know that like,
I mean,
we don't plan trips that just,
just to get,
just to enjoy was,
it is a booze cruise cruise,
but the whole car,
I don't think anyone had gotten a ticket to play shuffleboard with me.
Oh,
right.
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize.
I thought it was time out in New Orleans.
New Orleans,
they're going to depart from,
Oh,
I'm always going to be,
or he's going to be their big Jay's going to be there.
I thought you were planning a trip to get fucked up.
Oh,
no,
no.
It's the impractical jokers.
I misunderstood.
I thought you were planning this.
No,
no,
no.
If I didn't have that trip and the answer this,
if I didn't have that trip,
I probably wouldn't start drinking again right away.
But I'm going to be with Ari at midnight in the French quarter on Halloween and
that's when the bets over.
So I know I'm going to drink with Ari and so,
but I would like to like,
I'd like this month to simply reset my buttons and go like,
like,
uh,
just if you feel good,
I'd like to get,
I talked to already today a long for a long time and he's like,
he's like,
Bro,
I don't think you have a drinking problem.
He sent that,
he put out a podcast today where he just hates us and he's like,
I don't think if we're drinking probably a lady.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It's just about hating us and he's just so mad.
I like that text.
Oh yeah.
But it's tax was 34 minutes of that text.
He was just like,
this is ruining,
right?
This is so dumb.
I don't have a problem.
I don't want to fucking participate in this.
And he went,
he was like super angry,
super mean and attacks the normal,
right.
Normal.
And then I sent,
I sent a text where I misspelled something and everyone was like,
are you fucked up?
I was like,
yeah,
I'm hammered.
I quit.
I'm not doing it anymore.
So I talked to her today.
I was
like,
I was like,
dude,
in this month at all,
everything's up in the air.
Like if I choose to quit drinking forever,
I choose to quit drinking forever.
That's up to me by the way.
Of course.
But if I,
but,
but the point is,
I never once ever planned on stop drinking in my life.
Even when we started this bed,
I was like,
I still want to enjoy cocktails.
I didn't say that.
You did say that.
Yeah.
I love a cocktail.
I love,
um,
and I know this,
but my Achilles heels though,
there's planes and I think it spins me out of control.
It shows though.
And I know you don't,
I don't like that,
but can I rephrase that?
Can I rephrase that?
Yeah.
I said I'd never performed drunk and I,
and I don't for an early show I would maybe bring a cocktail.
I won't even touch it.
But I realized this weekend when I did those show stone sober,
if you said I couldn't drink,
that's a different box to put me in cause I like,
cause I was like,
I'm not drinking.
And then on that late show they were hammered and I was like,
and my instinct is like,
I'm going to get a cocktail and loosen it.
I'm going to fucking make this fun for me too.
Yeah.
But when your stone sober and they're fucking wasted.
Yeah,
it's a tad bit annoying.
Yeah.
It's called late show Friday.
Welcome to my personnel.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Those my in minor late show Saturdays are out of fucking control.
Like to the point where Taylor Thompson who was,
has been working with me,
we were in San Antonio and from stage she asked a bouncer to come to walk her
off stage.
Wow.
Yeah.
She was like,
I'm not feeling entirely safe with this audience like it,
but he's just fucking chaos.
You know what,
I realize we've never done this.
We were already all this time into the show,
we didn't play any open will Bartow family.
But let me just play one thing just for sure.
For the old school people.
Sure.
To open the show.
Okay.
Who's this?
Oh,
this fucking asshole slur.
Ski.
Yes.
Nice.
All right.
Don't bring anyone
to your mom so we won't play the whole thing,
but we always have to play a clip.
You realize Christina,
what times or what times are a cost question or a hot yoga class?
Uh,
I think,
let me double check.
I think we have a hour and a half or so until it starts to lower part.
You know,
I think what's really interesting for you this month and I think,
can we,
can I tell,
can I jump in and tell you something that I,
that I,
I was saying to someone the other day and I,
but I share this with you guys.
I regret how honest I am too.
Like I hate that I don't have that branding sensibility where I can brand myself
to be cooler than I am.
Like,
I hate that I'm too honest.
No,
it's called no boundaries.
Yeah,
it's bad.
Do you think that like no boundaries,
I'm guys pretend to be cool.
Is that you're saying or
no,
but like all the talk we do about booze,
I,
I can't lie.
No,
it's not that.
It's that there's,
you know,
public versus private.
I don't,
no,
I don't have,
you don't do that.
We know.
But I know there are no boundaries between what's inside and what's outside.
And maybe that's something to examine and you're sober.
Okay.
No,
no,
no.
I don't want it.
No.
Let me tell you something else.
I'm not gonna mention a fucking name,
but I'm not that person who is a,
is a lie on stage.
Oh No.
And,
and there are people that I see on stage,
like friend,
no,
just people that are alive on stage rely on their Instagram.
Ally lie on everything.
And it's a brand though.
This is my brand.
Like
I'm not that guy.
I don't think that's what that means.
I think that,
I think that that's my brand.
I think it can be a comedian.
And then there's some stuff that you don't have to share with everybody too is
what I mean.
Yeah.
That's all I don't think.
No,
no.
And you can still filter your real stuff through creative stuff.
Yeah.
And also maybe the self punishing stuff.
I think it's Kinda neat that you'll at least the sobriety it'll,
it'll lift the fog of booze to be able to think about the self.
Why no self preservation.
Do you know what I mean?
Self care I think is what the shrinks call it.
You know,
why are,
why,
why the overscheduling and the self flagellation
well I'll tell you right now.
I already started last night I started,
I signed up for like a bunch of these classes that I've always wanted to take.
Oh no,
that's great.
No,
no.
My wife's like stop,
cancel one.
You're not doing three different cause now you're just filling your schedule.
My schedule.
You do the same thing.
We've talked about this with the road.
Interesting.
Yup.
Right.
Who are scheduling overscheduling I I do way too many dates.
I'll throw a call in sick to work show at college,
I throw all of it on to one thing and then you also do like four weeks in a row,
one week off,
six weeks in a row.
One way like it's just,
it's way too much.
But I'll,
it's also kind of like in lieu of going to the store every night and working
out,
I work out on the roads so totally get that part,
but it is like you're gone a lot when you do that on a great amount and I'm so
grounded when I'm home that like I literally was saying to my friend the other
day,
I was like,
I think I,
I think I've been stuck in this podcast stand up ma mantra since I got out of
travel channel this past year.
I know pat kept passionate,
do TV.
I've got a project,
I've had a project in the bullpen waiting for us,
waiting for me to greenlight the script and I just talked to my buddy the other
day and I was like,
I'm not,
I'm just not in it.
I'm,
I'm sorry man.
Yeah,
like I'm not in it.
I don't really have any passion right now.
Like I just don't,
my passion is doing stand in and getting ready for this next hour.
That's where my head's at and then this week I was like,
Oh,
you know what?
I think I'm going to,
I think I'm going to revisit this project,
but I think I'm gonna revisit a different way and I think I'm going to try to
get passionate about something like that.
But Bar,
if you know that being home is best for you emotionally,
it,
it stabilizes you.
Then maybe the,
I mean,
I guess one of the goal be to maximize the time out so that you,
you make your money in the shortest time possible and then your home and then
you can be,
you know,
you can feel better.
That's all I'm saying.
Like,
yeah,
I feel it feels better.
It would,
my life would be,
that is a really interesting insight.
My life would be drastically different if I would do a weekend and then take a
week off and then like Joey a weekend and then say,
go,
we call sounds easy to do,
but then what happens is they go a weekend and then,
hey,
we got this college and they're like,
I was pretty good money for wanting show.
Here's the thing.
I wait,
wait,
wait.
Hold on.
No,
no,
no.
Backing up.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's good money.
Great.
Well,
can we push that offer to next quarter when I have an open,
it's just right now,
Joe.
Okay,
so then pass,
cause guess what?
My team Joey just said Joe.
He just had this conversation with me and I was like,
I know he was,
he got offered some thing and it was in between two things.
Like no dog.
Right?
You got to be these two fucking days.
Pick one.
Right.
I wish I do that.
Here's the thing.
No,
no,
no.
Here's the thing.
I,
I'm not to get too esoteric about about this,
but this has been very,
this has been a very extraordinary year for me in,
in,
in the word extraordinary,
not,
it's been good,
but it's been extraordinary in that it's not,
it's not been regular and it's been a little overwhelming emotionally,
you know?
Yeah.
I should probably bite my tongue,
but I will be very honest because I've always been honest with Tom about
everything
in December,
New Year's Eve,
unmoved,
no tickets at levity live.
They lost their ass on me.
Like I moved no tickets.
I did my special for showtime.
I did Dayton.
I remember calling and going,
uh,
sold out for the week and then found out they paper the entire room that they
didn't even read my contract.
They just papered the room,
no tickets,
removing moving paper the fucking room.
November,
December,
I was supposed to do a tour with Tom.
All of it got cancelled.
I got fired from travel channel.
I,
I was probably at my lowest when we started that weight loss challenge.
And I'm getting just hate from everywhere on the internet,
like posting stuff on Instagram.
And it's just destroy me.
And then,
uh,
I think a couple by the fact that we did that weight loss challenge,
the machine story goes viral and all of a sudden,
uh,
I start selling out and I sell out every single show this year.
And you,
and it's like,
I hope,
I don't know if you're gonna be able to speak to have this experience Tom,
but it's like a near death experience.
It's like,
it's like,
uh,
I remember a palm frond almost landed on my head one time in Marco Island.
It missed me by an inch and I didn't even see it.
Captive Orion.
Yup.
It's gone now.
Thank God
of Brian.
So,
but I remember it missed me and this French guy was like,
you are a lucky man.
You don't know how lucky you are.
You should really seize the day.
And I was like,
whoa.
And I was just going to get a cup of coffee.
I was hung over and I was like,
fuck it.
I'm going for a jog this minute.
I have my life.
I fucking hate my life.
I went from,
from something where like I was doing it and not a lot of people cared to then
people caring.
And I think it's like a near death experience where you go,
I'm going to really live my life.
I'm going to really take,
take these opportunities as best I can.
I'm very lucky and blessed that I can fill a calendar and then I can make money
and then I can put a pool in and I'm not going to piss this away.
I'm not going to like just,
you know what guys?
I know.
Granted I think what you're saying is right.
Yeah.
Working smarter isn't the same and you can,
you can make your money and,
and do it more efficiently.
So it's like you're taking care of yourself physically,
emotionally,
spiritually too.
You know what I mean?
So what,
what good are you to your family if you're dead at 50 cause you're working 51
weeks out of the year,
you're gonna you're burning it out,
right?
Yeah.
But I think harmful,
but it's been good.
But I think,
can I just say this like,
I think you're also speaking from your guys's perspective.
Like I would,
I would s I would say someone that is wasn't my situation in December.
No.
Would,
it would definitely go Berber you're doing the right thing,
right.
Get the money while you can.
Yeah.
Right.
It makes more sense to hear you explain it that way.
Yeah.
Um,
but I think also now that you're,
now that you're 10 months into this year and like you've,
you've been doing what you're doing.
I mean,
you probably do see how it isn't the way to live,
right?
Yeah.
I can't,
I can't do it.
Like next year I can't,
I,
I'll tell you this,
I'm doing it until February only because I'm shooting a special and February in
Philly and I know that the two months before I shoot a special,
I am out.
I'm doing standup every as much as I can to get ready for the special.
Sure.
It's,
it's how I write.
I feel like I,
I,
I paid the base all year and then when I go in,
I start looking at it and I go,
oh,
these are the clothes lines.
And that's those two months and a like.
I think December's a little bit of that.
But you're right.
I think coming this next year,
I would like to not,
I'd like to do what Tom does where he just goes and does.
Okay.
You know?
But I also,
I,
today I couldn't do what Tom does when you,
when I see you on a plane going to do a fucking interview and mantra and in what
you would call it and then do a show that night.
Yeah,
I saw that.
And I was like,
oh,
I'd have to be blotto drunk to get on that fucking Barbara.
Jut Really?
Yeah.
And now,
now after now having that one one fight under my belt,
I go,
oh,
maybe I could do a pro.
Maybe I could fly on perform.
Maybe I could.
Good man,
you can't.
I think what your,
your actual,
what you just explained made me understand your decision making because you're
like,
I got it.
I got,
I have to take these offers.
But I think having gone through this year,
you have to realize how,
you know what,
it's not fleeting in the sense that it's like,
Hey,
it's gone tomorrow.
You can tell agents that say like,
Hey,
so,
uh,
fucking DC it's,
it's um,
whatever.
It's October 1st.
You can be like,
no,
like look this,
get the schedule's too crazy.
Let's put them on the calendar for December,
January.
You know what I mean?
Like you can spread it out but you,
they will always take advantage of,
of me saying yes,
yes.
Always.
Our job is to bring you off or off only change
if you,
you know,
you can set up a thing where you go,
like,
I'm telling you guys now I
need a week off in between weeks.
That's the,
that's the new plan.
So book,
whatever,
you know,
bring me whatever you want.
But it's got to be week on,
week off,
week on,
week off.
If you,
if you tell them that like that's a Bert decision,
you know,
they're,
they're going to respect it.
They're going to bring you things,
but they're going to respect your decision.
It's always their job to try to step your boundary.
It's the agent's job to go,
yeah,
I know you're in,
uh,
South Carolina.
Would you mind tacking on Richmond?
And you're like,
no,
you're not.
You know,
it's true that like,
you do love that time here
dude.
I love it.
Healthier for it.
I love it so much that I,
that I,
but I,
but you gotta realize I haven't had it.
I haven't had it in 10 months.
I haven't had,
I haven't had a week off in 10 months.
I've haven't had shit off.
I've been working almost,
I mean,
no one's going to speak in hyperbole,
but like I've been working nonstop now.
Yeah.
And like the Australian tour was like two weeks straight and I just was like,
and I looked at your Australian tour and it's like five days.
Yeah.
Five fucking days.
And I look at mine and it's fucking two weeks and I'm like,
and then I go,
am I,
what am I doing this wrong?
Like I started like getting angry at people going like,
like jr when I DC wanted died to Sunday shows and I was like,
no,
I was in Australia when they asked great time to ask.
I was like,
no,
no.
And they're like,
well,
they'll give you,
you know,
we talked about percentages,
but they'll like,
they'll give you what you want.
And I was like,
no,
I'm not doing it.
I already told you I wanted to add those a month ago.
They should have got it a month ago when I said yes,
I said,
no sober October starts fucking nap.
Well that Sunday I want to be home.
Thank God I got it.
Fuck out of.
Right.
And so you turned down money and you turn down a show,
correct it,
I had gotten booked into cap city without my knowledge.
Like I,
I just,
I guess I had said yes,
but I don't,
I didn't know it.
It wasn't on my calendar.
And then I started and then I saw it pop up on my calendar one day and I was
like,
whoa.
I was like,
you got to cancel cap city.
Do you know how hard it was for me to cancel cap city?
First of all,
I have such this thing where I go,
I want them to like me.
Yeah,
like our warranty talking about,
well you don't want to say no cause are you afraid of what will happen if you
say no?
Yeah,
they'll get upset.
Dude,
I,
I've seen,
I've seen parts of this business that,
that I know you've seen
but I've seen it differently.
Like,
like I've seen parts of this business where people are,
dude I like,
I wish I could say names where they asked for more money or they went to do with
theater tour and then I've heard the conversation,
they're not selling tickets.
They fucking,
you know what?
That's what you get.
You think you're too much in this business.
And I always felt like if you come at it humble,
like I'm a worker,
a lunch pail guy,
do book me and all your fucking,
I'll do everything.
I'll do everything that that was the way to getting money.
I look at Joey,
Joey moves identical tickets to me.
I mean we're Joey's selling out every show he does you mean?
Yeah.
Joey.
Joey's does everything.
Ari does identical if not much bigger than me after.
That's what he just doesn't know because he hasn't been on the road,
but they say no all the fucking time.
Yeah.
Cause here's what Julia and also to Joey's credit,
he was saying no before he sold a lot of tech.
I was going to say that is that Joey Diaz was saying no when he was at a
whatever lower rung on the totem pole because it's a habit of I'm important.
What's important to me is important and I'm not going to let these boundaries
get moved by the agent's pressuring a will if you don't do that.
Okay,
well we will let it happen down Sunday show.
Yeah.
Oh.
He's the reason I stopped doing so many shows.
How about this analogy?
Can I tell you this is,
I was thinking about this today cause I was like,
I'm sure we'll talk about because all the things that I talked to you about
privately are always open game and I know I talked to you about,
you mean you always talk about I'm working too hard that I'm working myself into
a grave.
Here's,
can I tell you the feeling I had,
I was thinking of this analogy today at your age.
I stopped,
I,
I left the playground and I went to go in for a play date with travel channel.
I went in to seem nice.
Was inside,
was indoors,
had x boxes.
I was like this would be nice.
I wouldn't mind if they sent me over to this forever and I could turn this into
what?
I could just do that.
That'd be really fun.
And then I came out in the sun setting and they built a fucking bad ass play
structure for you guys and stand up and I saw you on it.
You're like,
Bert,
come on.
You should have been doing this the whole time.
What the fuck were you inside?
And I'm like,
oh my God.
And Joey's like,
dog,
I only want to do the monkey rings and always like,
I'm going to play for a second and then I'm gonna go on a bike ride.
And then I'm like,
hold on.
I get to fucking play on those as long as I want.
And I feel like,
I feel like my mom's yelling going to come inside and I'm like,
I just got out here.
I didn't know that the light,
the lamps were coming on.
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah.
Like a standup blossomed in a way that had I not done travel channel,
who knows?
But now that I'm out of travel channel,
I go,
oh,
this is fucking amazing.
When you see how many tickets John Malaney is moving,
you're like,
oh,
like it's like you're just overwhelmed.
It's crazy.
I mean,
Jim Jefferies moving 3000 tickets in a night.
Like,
I don't,
I'm not comparing myself with them,
but I'm saying,
by the way,
what I'm saying,
for those of you that dark don't understand what I'm saying is they're not doing
the clubs right now.
So the clubs still need to fill it with people.
Right.
So that's where I come in and,
and Joey and Ari,
I'm saying,
I'm not saying that I'm not,
I'm not trying to put us exactly in the same situation,
but,
and now there's,
and now that the German ladies moving 100,000 tickets in Chicago,
there's a 1200 seat theater that's empty.
Right?
Right.
And me and him don't have a crossover and fans.
So there's a theater going,
we need to book people and that'll be me next year.
So like I feel like that's why I feel like
feel like I'm on the playground.
That Burke,
can I tell you,
just having known you for the last like decade or whatever,
is that this over work ethic?
I feel like it's,
it's been at every level of your career.
Like where you are,
you are featuring a hundred,
you are a hundred.
So when is it ever gonna fuck with me?
You gotta start to draw some mother fucking boundaries.
Now you're successful.
Now you've got the ticket sales,
now you've got the power to go,
hey man,
I'm not doing fucking five shows.
Fuck your Sunday.
You're there bro.
I don't,
I don't know if I'll ever have what you guys have.
I know which is which is,
uh,
I'm getting,
I'm done.
My show,
I'm going back to my room.
That's the essence of the whole fucking thing.
I,
I the overworking cause you
no,
maybe I feel like it makes me feel accomplished a right.
I don't have to think for working.
The overbooking oversee the workaholism.
It's like alcoholic.
Leann.
Leann will fold laundry if she's got nothing else to do.
And I go just to relax and she's like,
what?
I gotta do something.
I love land.
But like my,
my meet and greets are like an hour plus.
Oh my God.
But,
but I know,
I always tell Tom,
I wish meeting people,
I wish.
Do you remember the f you're the first time you did the,
you did the date and funny bone and you were like,
hey man,
uh,
they uh,
they really like it here and I was like,
oh,
it's a fun group.
Whose House did you go to?
And you're like,
Huh?
And you were like,
you're like,
yeah,
you go out with these people.
And I was like,
every night I grew up with staff,
every single night I go to the,
we throw a house party on Sunday nights that we all go there cause we get off
early and Tom's like,
hold on,
you go out with the staff,
the crew every night.
And I know,
I was like,
yeah,
that was turned into the fans.
I mean I do shows and they'll,
I'll go,
hey guys,
meet me at this bar.
We did the,
we did the,
the Wilbur Wright in January
saying I'm exhausted.
No,
that's what I'm saying.
Like I just,
it's so crazy.
You sleep like how much do you sleep?
Four hours on the road.
No,
no,
no.
That's the time to sleep when you're in these hotels.
What about like when you're home,
what we'll do you sleep?
How do you sleep?
I sleep pretty good at home.
How long,
what are we talking?
Um,
last night?
Probably seven hours.
Okay.
Yeah,
probably average around seven hours.
Well,
what happened Bart,
if you didn't schedule anything,
what would happen?
What would happen if I,
if I had stand up,
be my side bitch and I tried to focus on,
I'm just saying,
let's just say it's this week.
I can't even wrap my head around what you're saying because I'm going,
are you telling me if I did less standup and I focus on another project,
but I can't imagine doing that.
Just be,
can you just be for fucking,
you know what I want you to do this years though,
been the fucking challenge.
Listen,
he's got anxiety.
Here's the fucking challenge I wish Joe Rogan would,
would've put to you guys.
You go to an Ashram,
you guys go on a fucking silent retreat,
a silent retreat,
good for seven days.
None of you assholes talk.
You fucking meditate and you get any of your head.
And it's sobriety and it's vegetarian meals and it's quiet.
And what would happen?
Oh,
I would lose my fucking mind,
man.
I got a text.
Gender.
I know.
I wonder if what would happen.
I would lose my fucking mind.
I signed up for TM classes.
Yeah.
Great.
Do you know how many did you go to sign up for a TM classes?
Flight lessons.
Flight lessons?
Yup.
Okay.
All right.
What are you doing?
I'm officially not texting back forth.
We bill trying to find the right flight school.
Are you going to do a helicopter or plane doing a flip fix?
Just a plain single engine plane.
Stop.
It leans right.
Stop doing stuff.
It's three hours.
What do you want?
Do it with me.
I've done it.
Did you really?
Oh my God.
And assessed now.
Like a single?
Yeah.
Did you have your license?
No,
I tried
dude.
Like this.
The Fun police stopped my joy of,
it's like all I want
our first child,
our new barley.
I was really upset about the flight school thing cause I was like,
oh children.
Yeah,
but no,
but I thought it would help me get over my fear of flying if I could fly.
And then I was like,
I'm not getting in a plane with you.
I was like,
oh,
by the way,
you're definitely getting complaint with me.
That's how that works.
That's why I'm taking flight lessons.
It's going to press.
Are you,
so I've got a lot of things.
I'm building a fence.
No.
Oh,
the pool is the pool anyway.
They just filled in all the trenches for the pipes.
Yeah.
I've been excited for it.
I'm so fucking excited.
So like,
uh,
it's in a way,
and I don't mean this in a,
in a way that sounds like the less than positive,
but like it's like a trophy.
It's an accomplishment to have that pool.
Right?
Don't you feel like it's like,
dude,
it's like a mark of all the work.
Uh,
yeah,
there's uh,
there's a lot.
I don't,
I'm not like I wanted a pool forever cause I think they really prefer,
I think growing up in Florida you get home and it just makes you relax and plus
that it pulls her so common.
But like I,
you know,
I think this,
I think what's happening is,
you're right,
I am overscheduling myself.
I literally was like a on this impractical jokers cruise.
I want to go scuba diving and then I'm like,
wait,
what am I doing?
I'm gonna bring my scuba gear on this course.
But I,
I,
I don't know.
Push,
I think you hit it on the head.
I would even when we were texting and I said last night about going to yoga and
we were going to go out to Jo Jo,
like directed directly I think probably more at me,
but he was like,
hey,
this is like a serious class.
No fucking round.
Cause I think,
I think definitely I'd be like,
you know,
I mean we'll see tonight,
but I take yoga pretty seriously.
But like,
no,
this is a,
a very,
um,
like I pretty well documented thing.
We should tell a listening or viewing audience that what's really what's going
on is for the month of October,
we are bird myself.
Ari are completely sober.
Yeah.
Joe is no booze and told us to go fuck ourselves.
And then we're supposed to do 15 ari lights him up on his bond.
1590 minute yoga classes,
a hot yoga classes.
So Bikram Yoga.
Yeah.
And um,
I mean,
Joe's class gave me anxiety.
One thing.
This is a little different.
I mean,
that I felt like was,
I dunno,
it's still a thing as far as this challenge is like,
you know,
the weight loss challenge was,
was stakes.
The stakes were like,
you know,
you're going to get shamed for being the loser.
You're going to,
you're going to,
someone's going to shave your beard.
Yeah.
And,
um,
and you're supposed to,
you know,
take the other person on a trip or someone was gonna pay for a trip.
So like,
there's these stakes.
This one's a little more like,
a little more broad,
a little broad.
It's still pot.
Like,
the worst thing that happens is like you're sober and you're more in shape.
Yeah.
I think it's fluid in that in that if we decide mid month that we realize what
the state should be,
I mean are is really are he really wants to do a decathlon and find out.
I totally get that.
The one thing about like I tried to emphasize was like you don't want to
announce that when like like we're going to do the decathlon this day.
Like when you don't have a location you'd have it locked down.
Like you're just gonna end up in raging people who would want to go the website.
The one crazy thing,
and I don't know if this is the byproduct or that that Joe enjoyed or that I
enjoyed or that you enjoyed.
I don't think Ari really got a biproduct side of that first challenge was I,
I really will say a lot of people came up to me and said,
dude,
me and my buddies also a hundred pounds.
Yeah.
Now a lot are saying that they're going to join us.
Dude,
it is aggressive.
It's much more than the fat challenge.
Yeah,
it is.
Sober October is been,
has gotten huge and I think mostly because Joe wouldn't quit smoking weed.
Then it got a job.
It got much bigger cause everyone's like,
everyone's like,
all right,
fuck it,
I'll do it.
I'm in with the bird and the,
the,
the common thing I get at every meet and greet,
or at least the one that didn't,
DC was the most recent one and in Australia,
all the meet and greets I did in Australia,
those were fucking aggressive.
I'm going to talk a bit about a misstep of boundaries.
Hey guys,
I'm at the fucking Sheridan.
I'll see you there in sane and everybody would go,
oh,
is a thousand seat theater.
I didn't realize how big that would be.
We overran our bar of like,
I was at the Sofitel.
I was like,
I'm at the Sofitel.
It was in Brisbane.
I'll see you guys there.
Fucking like to the point where it,
a couple times I got scared.
I would go crazy if somebody had done that to me.
The first thing I would do,
I would,
I would tell the tour guy,
I'd be like,
go into my room,
empty the fucking packed my bags and we're getting in a car and we're going to
do another hotel in the Hilton.
Oh,
right.
Fucking now I'm the one that told them.
I know what I'm saying.
Like if some,
if somebody had done outed my,
I'd be like,
we're fucking moving hotels.
Yeah,
I'd fly home.
I wish I had that.
I wish I had that in me.
I like that though.
I liked that.
What part of that do you like?
Can I tell you?
This is a flip part's fun of that I strangers who you don't and not that they're
all bad,
like our audience is actually very cool people,
but it's a thousand of them at your hotel.
Are there,
is there,
what's the fun of it?
Told the bartender,
I said,
do you mind if I invite some friends back after the show?
And he was like,
yeah.
He said,
well,
you guys stay up until two.
He was like,
yeah.
I said,
it's like he's like 22 many.
He's like,
Oh,
you can bring everyone.
And I was like,
okay.
So I just announced it on stage and I was like,
he was they,
and they don't work for tips there.
So he was just overwhelmed.
But he loved it.
They loved the idea that they're moving that much booze and we drank them out of
everything.
And uh,
but what I like about it and I,
and then this might be shortsighted,
but like in college,
when you saw a band performed,
did you want to talk to that lead singer or were you like give them space
because the space yeah.
To know your heroes?
No,
no.
Oh,
I had a burning the first time I ever saw Dave [inaudible],
Dave Chappelle perform.
Yeah.
I didn't know who he was.
I know he's a good comic.
I didn't know he was like accomplished.
I was 26 I was 25 years old,
just moved to New York.
And I,
I must've given him an ear beating about how funny he was.
By the way.
He's already a millionaire at the time.
I was like,
dude,
you need to stick with this.
You are absolutely hilarious.
You are fucking like,
I can't tell you.
And by the way,
he's probably 21 at the time,
or maybe he was 25 to be closer was 25 he was so kind.
He was so kind.
And he was like,
thanks.
And he was like generous.
And then he walked away and,
and I think to meet you,
Martin said,
what are you talking to Dave Chappelle about?
And I was like,
who's Dave Chappelle?
He's like,
that guy.
I said,
oh,
I don't,
I was just telling him you should stick with,
and he's really a great comic.
And he's like,
dude,
he's fucking famous.
I went,
what?
He's like,
he's got a movie coming out called how high or whatever.
Hi.
Hi me half baked.
And he's like,
he was in Robin Hood men in tights.
I go,
Oh shit.
That's the guy.
Yeah.
And I was like,
oh my God.
But the fact that he was that fucking cool do never left me.
The fact that ship that a tell when George was born took me out partying like I
never lost on me.
And the fact that we walked into a bar and when a tell walked in,
the place went nuts and they were all over him.
I was like,
that blew me away beyond like,
I mean,
I loved his material,
but that connection he had with them,
I was like,
dude,
give me that one time,
that party guy kind of thing though.
No,
no.
It's just a generous person.
Like a guy who's like,
I'm willing to,
I'm not any different than you.
I'm just,
I'm a fan of comms.
I'm a fan of bushes.
I'm a fan of Ari's.
I'm a fan of Joey's.
I'm a fan of Joe's.
I'm a fan of,
of,
of Jo Jo Koy fleet past bars.
I'm a fan.
All of these people too.
I listen to all the podcasts too.
If you want to talk,
let's talk.
Yeah.
And I think,
I think maybe I'd started that and maybe I,
maybe I've gotten it now.
Maybe I should get away from that a tad bit.
But yeah,
like,
I mean,
I don't shut people down or not talk to people,
you know.
Uh,
I met a guy,
this is one of my favorite stories ever.
I met a guy sitting next to me at lunch and he goes,
uh,
the machine sitting right next to me.
I go,
hey man,
what's up?
I mean by myself.
Where are you?
I have no idea.
It had to be very,
some are very recent.
Okay.
Cause this is a very round the road.
I'm on the road machine.
And I was like,
what's up man?
He was like,
uh,
he's like nothing man.
I gotta tell you I love,
I love your podcast.
I listen to all you guys.
I was like,
oh,
cool.
And he's like,
what are you doing here?
And I said,
Oh,
I'm doing this,
whatever.
I'm doing the club.
He's like,
uh,
oh that's great.
Uh,
what are you doing at night?
And I was,
suites are bullshitting or food gums.
We still keep,
we're sitting like almost next to each other,
but look close.
We talked,
we just keep talking and he gets up.
He's like,
hey man,
I got to say I,
it might've been in La,
it might've been an la.
He goes,
I gotta say cause I,
but they was in la.
He goes,
I gotta say,
uh,
you're really fucking cool.
I was like,
I appreciate it man.
And he's like,
I met
Tommy the other day.
He goes,
I said,
Tom,
it's Tom would,
hey,
I'm going to eat dinner.
I'm trying to get this dinner or whatever.
You were like,
Hey,
you are,
you're nice.
You're like,
hey,
how you doing?
And he's like telling me I'm,
and you're like,
Eh,
I'm going to eat dinner.
And I was like,
in my head,
I was like,
I wish I could fucking do that.
I can't believe you would the same guy,
same guy.
That guy's definitely listen to this.
He was dead.
I don't know where I was.
I want to say I was in la only because I might even done with the girls or
something.
Hmm.
I did meet a guy like the day after we all were on Joe's.
Yeah.
And,
and he said he was at the table next to me.
He was like,
Whoa,
because I've just listened.
Yeah.
And uh,
he goes like,
Holy Shit.
He goes,
I'm just listening to it like a five minutes ago.
And I was like,
oh,
that's cool man,
but be done automatically.
I,
my,
my story is different.
If someone says that,
I go,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
Let me see.
Like I can,
I go,
yeah,
that's cool.
Goes,
ah.
He goes,
I don't even know what to say right now.
And I go,
I'm going to order some food.
So yeah.
Okay.
Where were you at?
A Sushi restaurant.
W uh,
where in the area and this area.
Oh No,
it wasn't the same one that is,
that is the story.
I'm about to order some food or something.
It's just very casual.
Not a dick,
but like,
yeah,
like,
this conversation conversation's over.
But the difference between
between what Tom does,
which is like,
Hey,
I'm,
I'm nice,
I'm nice to people too.
And I actually,
I've gotten a nice conversations with fans.
Absolutely.
But then there's also a kind of thing where you go like,
all right,
I think I should go home.
And just like keep my space and then kind of have my time.
Yeah.
And let them have their night and then I have my night.
Right.
But I'm respectful and I try to be kind to people because it means a lot
to people,
man.
I'm not,
but I don't want them in my hotel lobby a thousand of them.
No,
that's the totally different thing there.
Yeah.
Do you,
uh,
when you,
when you're in an airplane and people are falling on,
yeah.
Do you feel guilty that they didn't get enough time with you?
When they say,
Hi Mike?
Oh my God,
what's the craziest stuff?
Yesterday people were boarding it.
Oh my God.
This guy was like,
oh shit,
the machine.
I was like,
what's up man?
He's like,
dude,
I was just,
but the line's moving.
And I was like,
oh,
I want him to finish his story.
But I like,
I'm not,
I'm not emotionally involved in it.
Yeah.
So it was just listening or are you good?
Oh,
let's just talk.
I can talk to them.
No,
but I wouldn't put it past boundaries.
I don't have boundaries.
I do not have one,
so.
Right.
I'm telling you I know boundaries,
but you do have cool banks.
That's what I just noticed.
Right?
Yeah,
that's better.
Oh,
um,
oh,
you left your spray can of stuff here.
Last time you were in sprinkle hair.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
Rogaine.
Yeah.
Oh for real.
Oh fuck.
Thank you.
I probably left it for you cause I have a perfect hair.
Um,
yeah,
I,
I think you said push.
Okay.
Is,
uh,
like I'm excited about doing podcasts with like insightful people this month
because we're,
we're doing one in a couple of weeks we'll come out,
but um,
okay.
But yeah,
I have,
I should,
I should change
my lifestyle and the way I work and I think that will change my lifestyle and
the way I,
I be healthy.
Like if I would,
if I was home for a week,
like there's,
there's no booby unsolvable and you'd be so good.
We'll,
we'll talk about this,
I think a later Burt on your podcast.
I want to get deeper down this rabbit hole,
but look,
you know,
can we do it?
Would you rather,
I kind of feel like I want to do the one we did for Ari with a bird.
I'm just curious of what it is.
Let me,
let me see if I can pull up this name.
Where are you?
How do you find these fears?
You realize what's happening here,
Andy.
This is unsolicited.
Somebody just made me pay given in India.
I tell you how frustrating that is.
If I got this,
that person would have my phone number and my address and that's the
relationship I'd have with that fan.
I'd be like,
dude,
I really owe you.
Yeah,
well call me whatever.
No,
I wish.
I have no fucking fans.
Talk to Leanne about your boundaries.
There's some,
oh,
you have a folder called Burdis fat videos?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
of course.
Man.
It's fat.
Oh,
why is twice the same fat Albert [inaudible] Cordova,
Luxor,
Gilbert Christ,
Bert Kreischer.
You are a fat cat.
Uh,
you're a fast.
They can't then Tom Segura might.
Yeah.
There's so many man internationally that glass.
You were having problems
and
you
go,
you will have it with Rob Lee
shot
and you are
then job.
People just made these men like dozens and thousands were all over the world is
over fucking whelming.
Isn't that crazy?
Awesome.
Oh guys,
guys,
guys.
Hey guys.
Time.
One more time.
He's fat.
He's got a picture of me up in his classroom.
He's fast.
He's fat.
Okay.
I mean these,
these came in literally by the dozens men from all over the way.
The best one ever is that fucking pig dude who,
who won the eating contest.
That was great.
Not just a competitor,
but the favorite to win the dog.
This guy.
It's the most you can eat in five minutes.
So Richard,
I,
how often do you,
oh my God,
I know my,
you know,
my parents might fool you.
I'm,
I'm on.
Been on a giant diet and life changing stuff.
Um,
I've dropped about a hundred pounds in eight months.
Awesome.
So we're going to consider this my cheat day for the here,
but you know,
prepping gallons of water.
But you know,
I have two giant inspirations.
I'm first my wife,
second anniversary,
I want to say hi to her.
And um,
there's a comedian I love,
he's a big giant fat guy,
just like me,
Bert Chrysler.
And uh,
you know,
if the guy just starts giggling a little,
you still way bigger than I am.
But you know what inspired him?
There you go.
Actually saw him recently where he lost uh,
uh,
one of somewhere.
I don't remember somewhere that I was recently.
Uh,
he gave me,
gave me like a Jersey from one of the,
cause like one of those contests,
he lost it.
Oh,
a bunch more weight.
Really?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But he um,
yeah,
there there's is,
I'm a,
I'm blown away by that.
I get nothing from fence.
Really?
No,
I don't like,
I mean,
well maybe I do,
but I just don't,
I don't have like an email box that I look in.
Maybe that's the problem.
You need an email.
Yeah.
And then people send it to some other songs.
So many songs.
Do you have any songs
from Tom [inaudible] wife is Dina made a Hashtag.
Wiseberg so stop saying that.
I'm fat.
I got the job,
it just hasn't,
and it's been like three weeks.
All I get.
So tell me
like 50 songs,
you know,
there's people that literally right,
go,
hey man,
you're not that fat of course.
And then I go,
yeah,
no shit.
And they're like,
I thought it'd be huge.
I was like,
wait,
are you fucking kidding me?
Yeah.
Some guys,
some guys told me in DC this day,
the other day,
and he goes,
dude,
you are skinny.
And I was like,
I was like,
I'm not skinny.
And he goes,
well,
Joe said you're to 65 to 65 I think Joe said you were three 85 at one point.
And I go,
no,
I'm not to 65 and I go,
it's,
and then it starts making you crazy.
You Go,
I go,
you know,
Tom was fatter than me when this started,
right?
And there were like,
no,
I go,
hold on.
And I was like,
good.
He scrubbed the Internet of pictures of him.
I know it was,
you know what?
I think I said this back then.
I think some people didn't know.
Some people did not know.
Some people knew that I was fatter than you,
but that they got a thrill out of spreading the misinformation.
It's like a fake news article.
You're going to start Thomas drunk.
Yeah,
he was an alcoholic.
Great idea actually.
And then some people were like,
fuck no birds.
Definitely not as fast
cards,
your mom's house
the best.
This was the best one.
Uh,
this is my ice.
Listen to this and my car.
This one,
that's my favorite song that's ever been submitted.
I think it's one of my top five.
This is Ali's easier.
Yeah.
It's such a joy in your car.
I love this man that was listening to.
It's good.
It's a real song.
Yeah.
That's great.
She's fine.
Here we go.
I shadowed.
There's just so many songs.
Is it?
Maybe you just have one fan is really busy.
It's a lot.
It is a lot.
That's fucking insane.
It is.
By the way,
did you see Steven Seagal is interview?
We've always roasted him on this show for years,
but like he did another interview last week.
Did you see his look?
He looks like Eddie Munster more and more every really crazy it looks painted
on.
Yeah.
Has Your view of Donald Trump and his presidency so far?
I think that,
you know,
we have a really unfortunate situation in the sense that,
look at that,
uh,
even though he was democratically elected,
there are so many people out there who don't feel that that's the case.
And we have just,
you know,
uh,
wearing it.
Yes.
Always.
He's wearing a GI.
He painted his hair jet black Lexus painted his goatee,
jet black and he got smaller,
tighter villain glasses.
But I liked the spectacles better than I liked the yellow ones that he had.
But if you don't like his,
uh,
his fucking gun range shooting cops shooting glasses.
Well those made him look fatter and sweaty.
I don't know.
He's actually tightened up the look.
I prefer the looks fatter now,
by the way.
I've done this with my hair.
You have,
oh,
when I sprinkled it in one time,
yeah.
I just,
it went,
went right across and I was like,
everyone sprinkled it in.
Oh yeah.
I you talking?
Oh
yeah.
I get these,
uh,
this hair filler stuff.
Super Millionaires.
Cool.
And I used to sprinkle it in for birthday.
I had that.
That's when I really knew it was one of the Times I knew it was balding was when
I was in hair and makeup for something.
And the makeup lady who's like,
you need to put in some hair.
And I go,
well,
I chose yes and it ruined me.
I go,
what?
She goes,
just fill you in.
I'm going to go,
I don't know.
I don't even know who you're talking about.
She's like,
oh,
everybody does it.
Yeah,
I'll do it for you.
Glenn Beck does it.
That was the one that did it to me.
Really?
What did it look good,
Tommy?
Like,
well,
she didn't go crazy.
I mean,
she didn't do this if done properly.
It looks amazing.
Like basically takes the,
like some of the gaps and the shine out so it just looks more,
you know what it does?
It attaches
to the,
to the hair follicle,
makes the hair follicle thicker so you don't look like you have a full head of
hair.
You just,
it just,
it takes the shine out.
They did meet for the Fox one time and I was like,
and I came home and my sister was like,
Yo,
you got to buy that shit.
And then I did it for every travel channel show I ever did because I would see,
I would,
uh,
I stopped gluten.
That's how he says he talks with a different acts.
How you say it,
man,
trust me,
I'm a Russian gluten.
You most Ah,
Ooh,
the
lip licking about what's the gimp hand about?
Uh,
you know,
and uh,
letting me uprooting,
uh,
you know,
Eh is
great.
That was great.
That blue band,
by the way,
I got to tell you,
I got to tell you my Joey Diaz story.
Tell it please.
So I,
Joey and I talked last night.
He's like,
don't we go to breakfast?
So we go to this place,
we eat breakfast almost seven days of it.
And,
uh,
and uh,
Joey orders three eggs over easy.
Uh,
bacon toast.
Pretty respectable breakfast.
Yeah.
I just get coffee cause I'm,
I'm about to go for a run.
Yeah.
And uh,
I'm Wa watch him.
Have you ever seen him eat eggs?
No.
He uh,
he was very lightly butters,
his toast and then he goes in with a knife and cuts around the yolks.
It's sunny side up cuts,
I mean meticulously around the yolks.
And I'm like,
I'm like,
oh I guess cause I've done that where you take a couple of the yolks out cause
you want the egg whites but you don't want the yolks.
And I was like,
I've done that where you take a couple of egg whites out and you have one,
but where you get all the egg whites from the other ones that he throws away all
the egg whites and he goes,
I don't fuck with you.
I got my egg whites dog.
I just liked the yolks
and I was like,
that's my favorite part.
That's why I get a eggs.
Um,
uh,
poached eggs are the best.
Yes.
Oh,
you music cue.
Of course.
Always have to think this is what we did with Ra,
but I'm going to modify it even if not.
Um,
yeah.
Are you nervous about this yoga class?
Ah,
fuck.
Um,
not really.
Cause I'm not thinking about it too much.
I think I will be nervous when we're pulling in
parking and I'm walking up.
I might be like,
yeah,
we got to leave soon.
Neil section,
chunk
the urine homeless men,
homeless John Sex with your sister.
They gave a face.
Um,
would you rather,
by the way,
do you know Tom Petty died today?
Isn't that crazy?
Yeah.
66.
That's what I listen to.
The one or the other.
One of the other things that got me super excited about this challenge as I was
listening to already languages,
I think turning 50 and he was,
he had to have a surgery and he's like fifties when it catches up to you.
And I heard that and I was like,
whew,
cause you're about to have a birthday of,
I'm going to turn 45 and uh,
in on November 3rd in on that pay practical jokers crews.
Oh Wow.
Do you know how many people have told me for years then I looked like already
Lange everybody.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
For a long time.
Can I tell you how many people this week?
So we love you Tom.
What one guy said we love you,
Tom.
On the,
in this audience.
I'm Bert.
Anyone off?
Same thing.
Oh,
okay.
Are you ready Bart?
Yes.
Okay.
Would you rather be retarded?
So you live as a retarded person.
You mean in beauty?
Keep going or Alzheimer's?
No.
Or you get molested by your grandfather on a Ferris wheel as a child.
But there's funnel cake after
grandfather jerks you off on a Ferris wheel or I could do that.
But he feeds you treats afterwards.
Yeah,
I can do that easily.
Do that.
Only because,
only because,
uh,
like,
like I've,
we have a family friend who's got a kid with down syndrome.
Yeah.
And uh,
their worry is like their older parents and their worry is what are they,
what's he gonna do when they pass?
And I wouldn't want my parents have to worry about me like that.
Yeah.
That's why only for your,
but the I can get molested.
I think I might've been molested.
Yeah.
Wait,
what do you mean you don't know?
You have something there.
That night in question where I've gotten a concussion and something happened and
I was always curious.
How much older was the person?
A much older.
I was 13.
I don't know,
but I don't know.
I don't know.
Cause I got a concussion and they were performing medical exams on me and so
like,
but I was like,
this is the middle of the night.
Why are we doing one in the middle of the night?
But then I was like,
I'm not going to ask.
Uh,
I dunno,
but I'm cool with it.
I'm not,
don't want any problems about it.
You come.
No,
no,
no.
It wasn't bad.
It was just some fondling,
but it could have been like a testicular exam.
I Dunno.
See,
that's my problem is I don't ever think that,
but I overthink what I'm doing.
And in October,
um,
let's get a couple of big things out of the way.
First a reminder,
your special mother inferior comes out October 10th
flick and the trailers up now so you can search for it on Netflix.
Search,
Christina P,
just the letter p.
I'm not doing [inaudible] ski on that fucking thing.
And then the title comes up.
Save it in your studio and then when it comes Danny and watch it.
Yeah.
What did you,
well,
how did you come up with mother inferior?
It's a play on mother superior like it,
it's actually based on this artwork.
A Fan,
uh,
did of me as the Virgin Mary Holding Fifo,
our dog.
And I sent that to Netflix and I go,
this is kind of what I'm thinking and it was based on fan art.
Hey guys,
let's do this.
Let's help me name my next special.
This should be fun with your fans.
Let's help me name my next question.
You're going to get a lot of Justin.
This is a great idea.
Hey guys,
I'm shooting at the Trocadero in February.
We're shooting two shows,
but I'll be there for,
I think I'll be there for four,
but help me help me named my special.
That's a great idea.
I don't think that,
I haven't thought of calling it burnt Chrysler and has me on top of a burnt out
Chrysler.
Yeah.
Like,
like,
like with one arm raised in the sky in a speedo.
I've definitely thought about that.
That's not bad.
It's not bad.
It's not about,
it's not a bad way to brace the embrace the charge.
Yeah,
that's true.
I,
I've definitely gone is because I don't mind when people come to be burnt.
Chrysler,
it makes me happy cause I go,
oh,
then you know me.
Right.
Like in a weird way in some of those what's up burnt Chrysler,
I go,
Oh,
oh you were,
you know,
me and Tom,
you know Christina and me and Tom,
we were all friends.
So do you know what happened?
Uh,
when I,
I,
I'm going to say it's when we got to go,
but yeah.
Uh,
at the taping a few weeks ago.
Yeah.
Um,
show one is finished in Denver and the Netflix reps come back in the green room
and they were like,
that was great show.
You know,
we got one more.
We want you to do it in Spanish.
I know,
but like they're like,
that was all like,
you're good.
You know the first one went great,
you know that thing you want to hear.
Yeah.
And then I was like,
yeah.
And we just kinda hung out.
And then she stands there for a second.
She goes,
I don't have any notes.
And I go,
okay.
But I think his name was Bert Kreischer.
I started telling them
my name and your special,
yeah.
This isn't one part.
I just say that cause I,
I say,
you know,
at some point I mentioned obviously that I looked different,
right?
Yeah.
And they're like,
I get a big thing.
And then I go,
yeah,
I was in a,
remember the Salami salesman that did the last one?
Yeah.
And weight loss contest.
But every show I would start modifying different ways to say your name.
Yeah.
So I mean,
I think the first show I said burnt Chrysler and she's like,
I think it's Bert Kreischer.
I started lab.
So,
oh God.
And I go,
I'll probably say something different the next show.
And she's like,
really?
I go,
yeah.
She goes,
why are you doing?
I go,
it's disrespectful,
Ruth.
She's like,
oh,
it's disrespectful.
Yeah.
It'd be like goes gears Bezel.
I gotta go on my own Berg Christ.
Yeah.
Um,
anyways,
Chrysler's burnt Chrysler.
Leanne wants to be the call.
Forgot your real name just now.
Did you hear that?
I went Burke Chrysler.
Yeah.
Burnt Christ Leanne wants me to call it,
cause obviously I'm obviously the,
I don't think anyone will ever think I'll ever be able to do a show with my
shirt on ever again.
She wants to be called party on the boat.
No business on the bottom party on the top.
Why you started doing naked?
You could up the ante on your neck.
Special a hundred percent thing as possible.
Take about anywhere that people,
wait.
What's the,
the website,
Bert.
Yeah.
Listen to the Burke cast.
Uh,
where'd you next to show?
I don't know.
All right,
we'll go to his website.
I'm in Ann Arbor,
Michigan,
Chicago,
Chicago.
This month I'm doing Chicago.
Oh yeah.
Shawn Berg.
Monday through Monday.
Right.
Monday through Monday,
October 12th,
three.
I guarantee we were doing three shows on Saturday.
I guarantee it.
I guarantee it's October 12th and Arbor.
October,
October 13th,
Indianapolis and October 14th,
the hard rock,
uh,
in Northfield just outside of Cleveland,
two in St Louis,
tits at the pageant and two and Fargo Fargo,
North Dakota at the Fargo theater.
All right,
that's it.
Thank you guys for listening.
Um,
uh,
Bert and I are going to go do hot yoga for 90 minutes now and I'll have a full
report next week.
Thanks for listening.
Love you.
Thank you.
You're the best.
Hey
Baby.
Dammit.
Debbie out.
Yeah.
Oh,
I
bless it.
I'm like
dirty
talk
quicker.
You ever see the movie
babies was fucking loads of a.